good morning afternoon and good evening
to the global audience in front of the
screen
i'm very glad and honored to accept this
opportunity to
uh share some information on the market
we work together with thermo fisher
scientific
in china may as you know the
african swine fever outbreak started in
august 2018 here and became a
epidemic in china
so today i will provide some some data
in my presentation but may only based
on the public part comes from the
government
thanks for your understanding
this is the other line after this
sharing
so let's see some public data related to
the asf in china
so this data comes from the ministry
of agriculture and rural fears of
people's republic of china
we shot it as mara and from this chart
you can see
there are 179 official reported cases
since the very beginning and up to now
i mean as the as this uh showed it in
the figure
is to uh july the 24th 2020
and learning province the first fossee
we know
that asf funds in china have accumulated
the most outbreaks and you can see this
it is the only one
province was over 20 cases
and the esf have
devastated chinese wing industry since
august 2018
and you can see from this chart that
both way and the
source stocks are declining
from the second half of 2018 then touch
the bottom
one year later with over 30 percent loss
in both figures it is likely that
there will be sufficient markets
incensive
and political stimulus to put forward
with recovery efforts as a result
the 2020 ending swaying inventory
is expected to increase maybe
reach 80 percent level before the
outbreak
and actually you can read from the
numbers
when it comes to the 12 to the year
2020.
there is steady rebound
mouth by amounts on both swing and the
sole
stocks
and this is a second part we call the
powerful tool for asf
diagnosis
due to the severe impact that asf has
imposed on the swing industry we need a
real
effective and practical solution to
identify the virus in the front line
and to control the spreading this
picture
showed a recommendation list
back to june 2019 released by the
chinese authority
china animal disease control center
they have arranged the assessment on
around 100 products
from the market evaluating their
sensitivity specificity
specificity and their robundness and etc
and then made this recommendation
based on the top performance during the
test
and there are 34 products in total
shown in this list with only one
imported product
that is asf we wet max
ssb detection kit from uh thermal
feature
centipede
and the best balance between high
sensitivity and the high
specificity this is this summary comes
from our customers
and it's just like the two sides of the
seesaw so we need to balance
these two uh characters and there have
been over one million
tests been put onto the chinese market
to
carry out the precise removal of the
infect and surrounding peaks
so we use a metaphor as a tooth
extraction and over half
of the top 10 group in china have
adopted
valmax asfv by detection kit to fight
against the virus and we have
classified the usage for the
webmax asfv detection keys and scenario
one
the customer can now afford any risk to
carry out a non-infected peak or
any real infected one in the herd
so comparing to their profit that our
customers can mate
from each peak here around two thousand
rmb per fashion or twenty thousand rmb
per saw so the cost
at only one hundred per our one hundred
rmb per test
will be a margin and scenario two
the cost oriented customers
will choose a cheaper solution first so
they prefer the domestic brand on the
list of the recommendation
however when they encounter some
problems
during the detection they will choose
whether max
asfe detection keys to make the
secondary confirmation
and we'll use our results as the
confirmative one
and then report it to the peak
production unit
and we come to the last part the
application of asfv detection keys with
our customers
but first let's see a report
on the characterization of the
replication and the
rules of asfv circulating strength
in china it's a it is the report
and you can see from this study the
researchers showed the
instructional data on the asfe detection
by different
sampling methods you can see from the
two figures
highlighted in the red boxes and even
though with
a 10 times lower copy number
when using oral swamps on the world
genomic dna detection it can make
three days earlier than the other two
sampling methods
since the contact peak you can see from
the
left box the contact peak here
simulate the natural state of the peaks
this research this this research
illustrated an effective sampling method
which can be applied to the daily test
on each farm to make an early diagnosis
and control the losses
so there have some
there have been some changes happen here
from the blood collection to some non
invasive sampling like uh
the rectal swamp the natural ferro jail
swamps
and tears boss lamps oral swamps
etc so usually the swamps
collected from on the same peak will be
gathered into
one sample which is tested in pool of
three or four
with our mathematics as f3
detection kit
and this is the environmental sample
collection for
the rigs for the surveillance
and which is another important usage
scenarios for our
vat max asfv detection keys
samples comes from the railing the floor
and the feces
within one pin will be pulled and then
applied to the qpcr
test
with the spread of the epidemic over
china
the qpsr method has been accepted as the
most effective
way to detect asfv so the tests carry
out in the veteran
laboratories have also made a change
from the conventional immunoassays to
the molecular diagnosis
under under which thermo fischer
scientific
has always occupied the living
position in the world
and in the end let's get to the
conclusion of the today's sharing
firstly the industry
here has survived the disaster and
surely will get better day by day
and secondly the changes happened in
terms of
animal disease diagnosis are inevitable
and the last i believe
the more strategic cooperation between
my company
cahg and the thermal feature scientific
is
expected and sets for your attention
it's my today's presentation thank you